I also think that Marvel is on this
journey now of they're trying a bunch
of other stuff and it let's you know I'm
excited for them to see how all that goes
and it's hard to it's hard to project now
there are so many rumors still out there
um fan theories people want to see Iron Man
come back could it ever happen yeah Anything
could happen I'm really enjoying and all these
wonderful things I'm looking right down the barrel
I love you three thousand
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Marvel just revealed that they're
formally planning on bringing Robert Downey Jr
back as a couple different versions of Iron Man in
multiple future movies so we'll break it all down
there are a few surprises but it does confirm some
of our long-standing theories after Avengers
end game whatever it takes whatever it takes
no fears no regrets of course they were always
going to bring a version of him back at some
point like this was not the end of Robert Downey
Jr appearing in Marvel movies if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a bunch of big Marvel phase
five stuff coming up we are starting Marvel
phase five there's gonna be a new Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania trailer video for Kang
really soon more secret Invasion and more Loki
season 2 footage it is going to be crazy but you
probably saw news about Robert Downey Jr coming
back in your feeds recently it confirms one of our
long-standing theories the minute that he died in
Avengers end game snapping The Infinity Gauntlet
everyone assumed at some point they would bring a
version of him or a variant of him because we have
variance now to the Loki series back in some way
in the comics there's no such thing as permadeath
there were even people after Avengers end game
legit like on a lot of my just regular Marvel
videos who were convinced absolutely convinced
that Marvel would never do another Avengers movie
like oh sweet summer child let me tell you about
something called the comics there's no such
thing as them stopping Avengers movies everyone
everything comes back in some form eventually
the best example of that is Spider-Man no way
home last year canonizing Toby Maguire Spider-Man
and Andrew Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man and the
Netflix Daredevil series to the MCU through
the Multiverse they just did a version of the
Illuminati team with a bunch of X-Men Fantastic
Four Easter eggs in Doctor Strange Multiverse
of Madness if they were going to have Tom Cruise
playing the 838 Universe Superior Iron Man variant
of the character they're doing weirder and weirder
Concepts and characters from the comics bringing
Robert Downey Jr back is nothing compared to some
of the big twists with Kang that are coming up in
some of the weirder new cosmic villains that
we're going to see in the next few years the
real question was how would they explain in coming
back what version of the character would he be in
Robert Danny Jr himself has been talking to a lot
of people the last couple years about this and
even people like Joe Rogan grilled him on coming
back with twists like time travel is the door to
Iron Man totally closed because I don't believe
it is oh you guys can go through time now you can
go there's there was you know know you already
opened up that door let me ask you the question
if I pick the Jersey back up and put it on
wouldn't you feel a little bit like a crap
no oh here's here's what I think they go through
a few semi lackluster Avengers movies without you
ready for this I'm ready here's the scene there's
a moment where the world's fate is at stake and
they've realized they need a Super Genius and then
they figure out how to restart that time machine
great come on man is that the audience sees you
when you when you step out of that thing is this
your and can we you want a little arc on it too
because if this is your idea then you got to show
up for it too I'll do it I'll show up what do I
have to do I don't know I'll do whatever I have
to do we all have to do whatever Kevin probably
here's the thing is that do they still have that
they do they do it's digital I'll hold that
digital thing I'll do it but the the way people
would freak out if you came back come on even
though I don't totally think they're going to use
time travel to just bring the 616 version of Iron
Man back like bring him back from permadeath we
are getting ready for Ant-Man the Wasp quantumania
with a version of Kang he is all about time travel
he's a time travel villain essentially and will
be the main villain of Avengers 5 and Avengers 6.
but based on this new report about Robert Janney
Jr coming back for multiple movies it's actually
supposed to be a couple different versions of
Robert Downey Jr's Iron Man like it won't be the
same version showing up at a couple different
places it'll be Robert Downey Jr playing very
different versions of the character in different
projects the first big place is in the armor
Awards movie which is going to be a Marvel Phase
6 movie now it started out as a Marvel Disney plus
series about Roadie based on the comics version
of the armor War Story they adapted a portion of
that during the Iron Man 2 movie in the original
version of that story it was Justin Hammer getting
control of Iron Man's armor Tech and using
them to attack him underway on a series for
Disney plus based on Armor Wars a classic Marvel
story about Tony Stark's worst fear coming true
it's what happens when his Tech falls into the
wrong hands and this series will star beloved
member of the MCU Don Cheadle will be returning
as Jim Rhodes AKA War Machine just because it's
changed into a movie now doesn't mean the plot
has changed a bunch they just changed the way
that they plotted it out like it's a much faster
version of the story because instead of six hours
it's going to be a two hour plus movie The reason
why they turn it into a full-blown movie instead
of a Disney plus series is budget mostly because
they wanted to have a bunch of Iron Man armors and
it was going to be super expensive to do that for
the entire six episode series typically they only
spend about 150 million dollars on the Disney
plus series even if it's nine episodes or six
episodes the budget is still the same that's why
some of the episodes are shorter for like the 9
and 10 episode series and longer for the six
episode series because the budget is the same
one of the things they've changed about that
though is for stuff like Daredevil born again
because it's going to be 18 episodes obviously
they need way more money to do twice as many
episodes but there are two big ways they can
bring him back in armor Awards one is in just
basic flashbacks for scenes of him and Roadie
that we haven't seen before before he died in
India game the other and I think more likely is
his digital Consciousness just backed up before
Avengers end game like the Jarvis or the Friday
version of Iron Man but it's Tony Stark you're
talking to and in the comics after the second
Civil War he basically did this like he backed
his Consciousness up before he seemingly died but
what wound up happening is that his body didn't
fully Perma die and eventually they rebooted his
comic book so in the movies it's wide open for
them to adapt this twist and do whatever they
want to with it in the main MCU they cremated
his body and Scattered his ashes after Avengers
endgame that lake near his house Kevin feige the
other Marvel people has said that they don't
want to take back the sacrifice of that Iron
Man in endgame wielding The Infinity Gauntlet
by just bringing him right back as the exact
same character so I think that just means that the
original 616 Iron Man won't be physically coming
back which I think makes it less likely that they
would use a big time travel twist like Joe Rogan
wants them to use even though Marvel did copyright
The Avengers Assemble name for the movies in the
Disney plus series because they're going to
do a Young Avengers project and there is a
lot of Young Avengers Kang time travel twists with
young versions of Kang but I think that all just
confirms that however Robert Downey Jr shows up in
armor Awards it'll be a version of him in present
day which I think soft confirms that it'll be like
a digital version of his Consciousness which will
just help Rhody defeat whoever the villain winds
up being whether or not they bring Justin Hammer
back or it winds up being some other character the
other movie they're trying to bring him back for
as you would expect is Avengers 6 Secret Wars as
a Multiverse version of the character they didn't
confirm that his secret Wars character would
be another variant of Iron Man just that it was
Robert Downey Jr coming back as a variant of Tony
Stark so I'm hoping that they pay off the earlier
Infinity War Easter egg where he briefly became
the sorcerer Supreme in Doctor Strange briefly
became a version of Iron Man when they swapped our
merge basically there was a version of Tony Stark
in the comics that did become sorcerer Supreme you
just call him sorcerer Supreme when that happens
but Doctor Strange's title when he becomes a
version of Iron Man is the iron Mage we had
the what if series there was also a what if comic
book were a variant of Tony Stark does become the
sorcerer supreme but he builds himself a special
magically laced armor part of what Marvel does is
when they delete scenes like that like it's really
cool really wish we'd have seen it but when they
delete that Marvel will bring those scenes back
in bigger ways in future movies Avengers Secret
Wars is the perfect place to have a version of
Tony Stark show up who is the sorcerer Supreme
in his universe in the whole idea with Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty and Avengers seek Secret Wars is
that they're basically splitting one giant movie
the way that they with infinity war and Avengers
end game with like a big Downer Empire Strikes
Back kind of ending at the end of the first film
so during Marvel Phase 5 we're slowly gonna see
this new Avengers team in the 616 Marvel Universe
come together we'll see them on screen together
for the first time in Captain America four New
World Order it'll be like Falcons new Avengers
we'll meet Kang the Conqueror during Ant-Man and
the Wasp quantumania I believe he's gonna be the
version that we'll see in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
in secret wars during Kang Dynasty they're doing a
version of Avenger Kang wore from the comics where
it's the Avengers battling many versions of Kang
but eventually he will spank them heart like they
will lose hardcore they'll have the downer ending
kind of like Thanos snapping The Infinity Gauntlet
at the end of infinity War Kang will successfully
collapse the Multiverse into a single Universe
with one world like the battle World from the
newer Secret Wars storyline and supposedly their
new version of the 1 in 14 million chance of
winning storyline is Doctor Strange the other
survivors of Kang Dynasty searching the Multiverse
for more powerful characters to form a Multiverse
Avengers and it'll be a much bigger version of
the final battle that we saw in Avengers end
game with an Avengers Assemble but it's a bunch of
Multiverse even more powerful Avengers defeating
Kang after which they reform the Multiverse
repair the Multiverse however you want to
think about it with a couple minor changes to help
explain mutants X-Men showing up more in Marvel
phase 7 in the 616 MCU and some Legacy characters
coming back even more in the rest of all the big
Multiverse characters going back to their original
univ versus Robert Downey Jr's Tony Stark variant
included but also explaining that there's always
going to be versions of him out there that could
come back and it doesn't always have to be the
same version it's one of those Multiverse jokes
now like we have the Multiverse now so technically
everything is Canon there is no idea that is too
weird now that they can't pull off because of the
Multiverse let me know in the comments how do you
want them to bring him back during armor Wars and
how do you want him to come back during Avengers
Secret Wars there'll be a couple big trailers
dropping really soon they also just made a couple
big announcements you can click here to learn
about Ben Affleck coming back as a new Marvel
villain in Marvel phase five and click here for
my new Loki season 2 trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!